he tubers is Charlie so this is going to
be my Supergirl season 2 video they're
basically like from the ground up
changing the show to doing Superman
they're doing Superboy ma Nell to doing
Miss Martian they're doing Legion of
super-heroes and they're doing Lex Corp
so this is going to be a breakdown of
all the crazy stuff that's happening so
let's start with the biggest stuff first
Superman what's going on with him so I
think Superman is going to be butting
heads with Cara because she has this
idea about how she's supposed to be a
superhero but he's been doing he's like
the gold standard and is going to be
like okay yeah so you're doing a couple
of these things wrong I don't totally
agree with it so he'll kind of be a big
brother in that effect where he's trying
to mentor her a little bit and like the
show is going to be doing problems that
are big enough to warrant his presence
as far as I know he's only going to be
in the first two episodes of the season
then he'll come back later on a
recurring basis so they have like a
two-hour story that they broke in half
that they're going to tell to lead off
the season it'll be 22 episodes total
I'm expecting to see Superman like
physically see Superman in less than
half of those but one of the other big
changes in the way they tell store like
Superman is a big part of the way
they're telling stories this season one
of the big changes from when it was on
CBS and season 1 is that it's going to
be heavily serialized in the vein of the
flash so like on the flash they had like
the big zoom arc that went over the
entire season there'll be things like
that happening on Supergirl season 2 so
they'll be like really big stories and
really small stories that only go over a
couple episodes one of the big stories
is Cadmus labs if you don't know what
Cadmus labs is think of it as like a
slightly more evil version of STAR Labs
and mercury labs on the flash so because
the flash has used the particle
accelerator explosion as a way to
surface new villains like oh you know
this big explosion goes off and creates
all these metahumans some of them are
good some of them are bad and it leads
to all these crazy adventures so I think
Cadmus labs is going to be the catch-all
for them to surface really weird really
crazy stuff mostly if you haven't read a
lot of comics most people's only point
of reference for Cadmus labs is clone
Superboy so what I think is going to
happen is is we'll see a bunch of people
from the Superman Supergirl comics come
out of Cadmus lives like them
experimenting doing really crazy stuff
but here's the thing I don't think that
they're going to do clones
superboy I think the TV show is going to
do a version of Superboy I just think
that it's going to be mon el because the
TV show has kind of already done a clone
of cara and that was what bizarro was in
season 1 so just careful for spoilers
for Supergirl season 1 and I'll explain
while they're probably not going to do
the Conner Kent that you remember from
the comics or even from Young Justice I
feel like most people's point of
reference for Conner Kent is actually
Young Justice but what I do think that
they can do is surface cyborg Superman
from Cadmus labs because during season
one we learned that Martian Manhunter
was only emulating Hank Henshaw so he's
like a good person masquerading is a
really bad person but the bet like the
real bad Hank Henshaw is still alive
somewhere out there he was believed to
be dead but he's still alive I think
they'll resurface him as cyborg superman
eventually so in that same vein Cara's
adoptive father Dean Kane is still alive
and it has something to do with Cadmus
labs so you know for like a brief period
I was like wouldn't it be so amazing if
Dean Cain came back as a twisted cyborg
superman like they found some way to
twist i don't think it's going to go
down that way but I do think that Cara's
father's gonna be tied to Cadmus labs
this season Dean Cain will totally come
back on the show and some really fun
plot like they brought John Wesley Shipp
back on the flash they'll do the same
thing with Dean Cain so on top of that
it's getting even crazier like they're
doing all the crazy stuff that I hoped
that they would do Miss Martian is
coming on a TV show
she'll probably be involved in some sort
of secret white Martian plot if you
don't know who Miss Martian is from the
comics she's basically like a white
Martian that survived the destruction of
their planet who is masquerading as a
green Martian so green Martians like
Martian Manhunter equals good white
Martians equals evil so the big twist
with Miss Martian is that she's like an
evil Martian that's trying to pass as a
good Martian in the Teen Titans they
have this big arc but then she also
tries to go good so she's got this
really complicated psychology that makes
for really awesome TV so I'll be really
fun to see what they do with Miss
Martian this season but I almost forgot
Legion of super-heroes
a lot of you saw ma Nell and you're like
hey wait a minute is that going to be
how they're going to do Legion of
super-heroes is that how it's going to
work so MA Nell is part of the Legion of
super-heroes but they're a team from the
very very far future but during season
one we saw Superman's Legion ring inside
the fortress of solitude so I feel like
ma Nell will be like a backdoor to later
Legion of super-heroes stories so get
really hyped to see some Legion Easter
eggs this season but through the four
night crossover it seems like she's
going to be on a different earth so just
to be determined in terms of merging her
characters with the characters from
earth one so let me know in the comments
do you think that ma Nell will be the TV
show's version of Superboy in what do
you think is going to crawl out of
Cadmus labs the season do you think that
we'll see a version of cyborg superman
surface on the TV show the site no big
side note I almost forgot I've talked
about this in previous video so most you
probably know about it already but they
are doing Lex Corp Lena Luthor who is
the sister of Lex Luthor will be on the
show day to day that will be played by
Morgana from Merlin so I'm really happy
about that Lex Corp now exists like it's
confirmed Cannon on Supergirl so really
like Batman aside there's almost nothing
that the TV show cannot do from the
comics so it's going to be super weird
super serialized and super intense this
season so I'm really hype about all the
changes they made it's gonna be a lot of
fun but congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Alexander Hu and a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
because it's been a couple days since
I've done Marvel my next video will be
Marvel so that should post later tonight
so get hype so much awesome comic book
stuff is going to be happening with the
TV shows this season while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my Jason Momoa Aquaman teaser video and
you can click here to learn all about
the Shazam movie also connected to
Justice League so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you